-
>> THERE IS A PRICE WE PAY
FOR LIVING IN A FREE
COUNTRY, WHEN YOU HAVE FREE
SPEECH YOU ALLOW PEOPLE TO
SAY STUPID THINGS.
WHEN YOU HAVE VERY FEW
CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENTSES FOR HOLDING
OFFICE, YOU SOMETIMES ELECT
PEOPLE THAT DON'T LIKE THE
COUNTRY THEY CLAIM TO
REPRESENT, THIS COMES
TOGETHER IN CASE OF
REPRESENTATIVE ILHAN OMAR.
SHE CLAIMS HER CRITICS ARE
ANTI-MUSLIM AND
ANTI-IMMIGRATION AND
ANTIBLACK AND SEXIST.
WHAT IF -- CRITICS
DON'T LIKE IF IF YOU SAY
STUPID THINGS.
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR ALSO
SAID, I DON'T DEFEND OR
EXPLAIN THE RISE OF CRIME,
THAT IS NOT MY JOB.
THEN SHE IMMEDIATELY DEFENDS
AND EXPLAINS THE RISE IN
CRIME.
YOU WILL NEVER GUESS WHO SHE
BLAMES FOR CRIME CRIPPLING
HER DISTRICT?
SHE BLAMES THE
POLICE, THEY ARE TO
BLAME FOR MURDER, RAPE AND
CARJACKING, DON'T BLAME THE
PERSON ACTUALLY COMMITTING
THE CRIME, BLAME THE POLICE.
IN HER WORLD THERE IS NO
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
NO ONE IS ANYONE'S
FAULTED UNLESS YOU ARE RICH
OR A COP, OR JEWISH.
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR PUTS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MURDER
AND RAPE AND ROBBERY NOT ON
THE PEOPLE COMMITTING THE
CRIMES, BUT ON THE PEOPLE
WHO RISK THEIR LIVES TO
PREVENT AND SOLVE THOSE
CRIMES.
MEDIA JUST IGNORES THE IS
UPDUPLICITY.
WHEN REPUBLICANS SAY STUPID
THINGS, THE MEDIA IS QUICK
TO REPORT ON THAT, WE SHOULD
ALL BE QUICK REGARDLESS OF
WHO MAKES THEM, BUT YOU WILL
NOT SEE MEDIA HOLE HER
TO ACCOUNT THEY NEVER DID.
IN SOUTH CAROLINA PEOPLE WHO
START FIRES, ARE CALLED
ARSONISTS.
IN MINNESOTA THEY ARE CALLED
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
FREEDOM ONLY WORKS WHEN A
CORRESPONDING
RESPONSIBILITY.
I WILL LOOK TO SEE WHETHER
THERE IS ANY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR A MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO
BLAMES CRIME ON EVERYONE,
EXCEPT THOSE ACTUALLY
COMMITTING THE CRIMES.
AND IF SHE HAS HER WAY
POLICE WILL BE DEFUNDED.
THERE WILL NOT BE ANY